Speaker 1: Donald Trump does a rally in Michigan
over the weekend.
It's outrageous.
Trump lies uncontrollably.
Next, let's go to the other people on the
stage with him.
They did an opening prayer, which started
with the belief that Donald Trump is the current
president.
They are.
It's what's fascinating is it's almost a religious
belief at this point together.
Speaker 2: So we pray father in heaven.
We firmly believe that Donald J. Trump is
the current and true president of the United
States.
You have raised him up for this season of
time to be used to be part in saving a nation.
Bless and protect him and his family from
any physical spiritual attacks and then his
voice through the people to righteous action
to bring godly men and women into elected
office.
Speaker 1: This is a really, really sick country,
guys.
We've got real problems here.
We have real problems and it is almost.
A religious belief, I mean, it wouldn't shock
me if soon they say, actually, you know, this
is no longer a political belief.
Our belief that Trump is currently the president,
God told us it's now a sincerely held religious
belief.
We want religious nondiscrimination protection.
I shouldn't give them any ideas, but this
country is in real trouble.
We also heard at this event from Republican
Congresswoman Lisa McClain, who wildly claimed
that unemployment is now at a 40 year high.
That's not
Speaker 3: true trouble.
We went from an economy that was booming to
a shambles.
What we have now is a shambles.
It's a complete mess.
Unemployment, 40 year high labor shortage.
We can't find goods
Speaker 1: at the store.
Now that is completely untrue.
As many of you know, unemployment is incredibly
low.
It's at 3.6 percent.
We're putting a historical chart of the unemployment
rate up on the screen, and as you can see,
it is very, very, very low.
Then Lisa McClain went on to say Trump got
Osama bin Laden.
Now some of you guys might remember Barack
Obama walking out and saying, We got Osama
bin Laden.
It was Barack Obama who got Osama bin Laden.
You could say it was against the law to go
in.
You could say anything you want.
But it wasn't Trump.
But that's what Lisa says.
Speaker 3: Well, President Trump was in office.
We didn't have a war, and I think he made
three peace treaties pieced caught Osama,
Osama bin Laden and Suleimani al-Baghdadi.
And this president is weak, right?
Speaker 1: Not true.
It was Barack Obama who got Osama bin Laden.
Last clip of Lisa McClain Lisa McClain says
migrants crossing the border are basically
all criminals, rapists, et cetera.
Kind of rehashing a Trump 2015 line.
Speaker 3: Come on in.
And you know who came in terrorists, convicts?
Speaker 1: Terrorists?
Who's that?
Speaker 3: Murderers and rapists?
And if we think the border crisis is just
a crisis at the border, we're gravely mistaken
and it's
Speaker 1: really, really crazy stuff.
And then last one for you, Mike Pillow was
at the event.
Pillow was interviewed.
He's still going on about machines, guys.
It's beyond belief.
Speaker 2: We have the bombshell evidence.
There's only one machine in the United States
now where we have you.
When you open up in there, it all is.
And that was.
Tina Peters took her back to grab a copy of,
you know, backed up her.
Speaker 1: That machine is my espresso maker.
You open it up all the evidence from the 2020
election.
I've got it stuffed in there along with all
the coffee grounds.
Speaker 2: It her last summer, when I had
my symposium, she was there from that time
on at least eight different cyber cyber cyber
experts.
Cyber experts did a seven month investigation
and, yeah,
Speaker 1: completely delusional guy.
And remember that he is suing all machines.
Speaker 2: We're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I actually I'm waiting to
find out whether my bicycle is technically
a machine, and if so, it's going into the
witness protection program.
Completely insane, completely insane.
We'll have these clips on our Instagram.
Make sure you're following us there at David
Pakman show.